mir zugeschaltet ist jetzt martin lacey
krone er ist beim circus krone dompteur
sie haben selber 26 raubkatzen was war
das erste was sie gedacht haben als sie
von dem fall der kleinen lea gehört
haben wie geht es mit kleine löwen bevor
das war natürlich unsere bedenken
ich hoffe dass hier geht das oder
allerersten
das kleine löwenbaby ist erst sieben
wochen alt wie dringend bräuchte es
eigentlich noch seine mutter ja also wir
wissen nicht genau alles um das ist weg
mutter natürlich es ist möglich da mit
der flasche gebern wir lassen uns hier
immer mehr sagt person nicht nähmen dann
weg aber gibt immer eine lösung das
vielleicht eine mutter will nicht haben
oder haben nicht genug milch und dann
natürlich rande erfahrung auch mit der
flasche zu geben die tiere
es ist sehr wichtig und dann würde sie
dann eine special mit stoff für milch es
ist nicht der beste sein bester ist
muttermilch aber bestimmt wir haben
stärke gewann
wir haben sowie ungefähr zwei löwen von
maine ganze 26 was du musst du mit der
flasche weil das ist einfach bis zu
schwach aber das ganz gesund wird
in ihren augen was wir jetzt das beste
für die zukunft von der kleinen leer wo
wir sie jetzt am besten aufgehoben war
solo mit tier ist allein der brauchen
andere löwen durch wissen ist begrenzt
und digital wir haben sofort reagiert
wir haben geschrieben zu land auch davon
dass die leeren auffangstation dass wir
brauchen hilfe
ich bin dabei egal was das finanzielle
hilfe einer platz das tier war meine
wunderschöne roth außerhalb vom bund
schon westling wo unser altes wir sind
aber ist ein riesiger länder dar
und jetzt kommt das punkt dass wir
mussten irgendwas bauen so dass firmen
bin auch bereit also wir lassen kein
tier im stieg auf mittel der kogit 19
seite ist sehr schwierig für uns aber
das verkauf von keinem tier und soziale
geht es sehr gut geht einfach weg wird
wohl sagen sehr sehr gut trotzdem ist es
immer wieder eine diskussion sollten
löwen tatsächlich in zirkussen oder
tierparks und zoos leben was sagen sie
dazu
ja aber zirkus krone alle wissen und
subtil geht es sehr sehr gut da haben
die best beleben
also wir haben unser ziel ist
beschäftigt dann gibt keine stereotype
wie bei uns ich kann etwas sagen gibt es
guten schlägt vom alle und darf ihr mann
muss man das auch verstehen gibt gute
tierpark schlägt tierparks gutes stück
des zirkus gibt es gute chance bot
schnecke chance bot und darf ich wollte
einfach sagen meine leute auf mich jetzt
das einfach sagen dass man schon sehen
jeder sitzplatz schon selber um wir
haben bei unserer amtstierarzt alles in
ordnung wir haben keine haben verklagt
und irgendwas also wenn man alles
korrekt hier und kommt vorbei und sehen
dass bei uns also haben überhaupt kein
problem aber allerersten formales zeit
ist dass das tier geht gut das baby
lösen und es ist sehr wichtig für uns
dass das haben auch finanziell
unterstütz blieben auch dabei vielen
dank werden gehört der löwe ruft also
schon aber danke für ihre einschätzung
dazu weiße löwen king tonga dann auch
liebe grüße dahin natürlich danke mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bet schau dich hier das nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren